i you know i don't know what it what it
was about beans
you know i know he had some issues with
his voice later on but like
you know he had his legal problems but
it seems like
[ __ ] just kind of hit a wall for beanie
yeah um
what do you think happened to like his
career i think that the rockefeller
split up
i think well i'll say
i'll say um honestly bro and beans like
he'll respect this because like i love
him bro like i'm muslim i took my
shahada in his living room like that's
how close we are
we might not see each other all the time
but that's my brother for life i say
from my perspective is that
he never really took the time to learn
the business now he was a great asset to
the business
but as far as like i always had this
thing in my mind where i felt like when
jay
said he got rid of was going to get rid
of rockefeller he would have gave all
the philly
he loved them bro like i seen jay show
more favoritism to the philly dudes than
the brooklyn dude sometimes you know
what i mean
dude like bleak glass hey it felt that
way though from a fan's perspective it
felt like
jay he really loved like the grittiness
so they rap style and how real it was
and their perspective but think about it
everyone
i mean young young guns dropped out you
know freeway dropped out like you know
i think i just think that beans and then
not i don't want to just say he didn't
learn it i felt like
you know he didn't have i can't say he
didn't have the right personnel because
it's people that i know that was around
him
but i again i was a kid at that time i
can't speak for how they was handling
business because
i just when i wasn't supposed to be in
the room i walk out
still to this day bro if i if i came
into your studio and you was having a
conversation i won't even walk in a room
right i know it like if you tell if you
give me the
if i if it's permissible for me to be
there i'll be there but i stay
in my place so a lot of [ __ ] that was
going on when certain conversations is
being had i walk out
because it ain't my place to be in there
so i i you know yeah i think what with
beans at least from a fan's perspective
perspective it just kind of felt like he
didn't leave the streets all the way
alone
didn't and that's another to to to his
detriment possibly this is what i be
saying about the streets man it's like
we we you love the streets when you're
growing up when you when you young and
like if you live in that life but once
you get older but i guarantee
everybody and i got i got homies that
like did 15 years in prison
biggest gangster in the jail biggest
gangster in the street and they like
man i'm not doing no like i made a
mistake
yeah i mean i can't change it but that
[ __ ] is a mistake bro
and and the marketing aspect of music
that involves the streets is it looks it
looks cool
it looks cool to you facing and also it
helps sell records
it does but it does but i don't know man
that [ __ ] is music is a hard thing for
me to deal with sometimes because i be
feeling like sometimes that i'm
i'm a part of the [ __ ] that i don't
agree with a lot
because as much as i'm saying all of
this like righteous sound and [ __ ]
i still love songs about people killing
people of course you know i mean like
i just i don't know it's like like you
know what people
say oh you uh what's what's the word um
contradicting being contradicted or
being a hypocrite
right yeah hypocritical [ __ ] yeah being
a hypocrite i feel like that's almost a
part of being human because like you
feel different times
you feel different ways at different
times you don't always sometimes bro i
wake up and i want the world to end and
sometimes i want to save the world
you know i mean but it's just how i deal
with it